und wir sprechen jetzt im medianer wert
hallo frau will hat sie haben sich am
samstag testen lassen haben sie jetzt
endlich ein testergebnis
ich habe leider immer noch rangers
ergebnis ich habe gestern mehrmals
angerufen und heute früh habe ich auch
schon wieder zwei mal probieren es ist
immer wieder dieselbe hotline geschaltet
uhr kommt es in anleitung belegt bitte
versuchen sie es später noch einmal
haben sie denn verständnis für die
bayerischen behörden oder sind sie sauer
also nachdem man überhaupt nicht an
testergebnisse ankommt kann man langsam
sommer werden würde ich sein und was
geht in ihnen vor
was geht in ihnen vor
sie müssen ja wahrscheinlich total
verunsichert sein weil sie ja gar nicht
mehr jetzt wissen sind die positiv sind
sie negativ sollten sie eher zu hause
aufhalten
ja es ist ein komisches gefühl man weiß
nicht wirklich nicht richtig wie man
sich verhalten soll
ich versuche es halt wirklich zuhause
das sie zu hause zu bleiben
aber die normalen sachen ihn mal
einkaufen das tue schalt und hoffe halt
dass ich negativ bin